[Applauso]
[Musica]
bene benissimo stare se io e te la vita
è un simbolo challenge trasforma questo
slime challenge e vediamo chi riuscirà a
trasformarli meglio voi dovrete portare
i miei sondaggi come sempre e oggi
abbiamo qua con noi i nuovissimi crimini
noi abbiamo tantissimi che bello questi
sono i tuoi tweet i front slide ve li
ricordate però sono ancora più crimini i
colori sono stupendi sono più soffici
più cremosi e più squizzi praticamente
dentro ci sono due slime perché sotto
c'è uno slime trasparente colorato
alcuni sono anche glitterati bellissimi
e sopra se uno slide bianco
così una volta che togliete il dischetto
al centro di plastica potete mischiarli
si crea una valence slime bellissimo
sono giudici colori diversi
lì come potete vedere e li trovate in
edicola a 2 euro e 50 in allegato alla
rivista mi raccomando fate visto impresa
re la rivista di collection e per ogni
turno dovremo pescare a caso uno dei
grigi soft e dovremo provare a
modificarli voi dovrete votare nel
sondaggio poi chi è riuscito a
modificarli meglio ognuno potrà decidere
come modificarlo senza copiare l'altro
come verifichiamo che non possiamo
modificarlo questo egli ritmo ad esempio
schiuma da barba del free cio palline
the line sono già bellissimi da soli ma
anche modificandoli saranno superbelli
almeno spero di vincere
siete frasi lasciate un bel mi piace per
altre challenge slime presente cosa
silipo con tè freddo anguria affronta il
primo ci vediamo gli occhi chiudere gli
occhi e peschiamo un crimi stop a caso
per scarone
io ho postato il creevy soft arancione e
tu quello fucsia ma che bello allora
apriamo li andiamo a vedere come sono e
poi decideremo con modifica va bene col
mio slimer stannis notes e morbidissimo
tempo kings e super soffice parete che
bello rimane un arancione chiaro ecco
vedete qua c'è il dischetto per
separarli ed ecco file cristalli slime
vedete che questo è molto più
trasparente ma comunque sono super e
flessibili hanno un sacco di fantastici
quindi andiamo ad unirli tornata così
ancora più grande e quindi dovrò
decidere come modificare questo line
sarà super divertente
se invece si trovò veri e qui
così tiriamo fuori subito la parte
bianca che tutelano questa è la pausa è
chiaro esatto da parte di via camporosso
ruolo sastra rosetta anni fuori il
colore scelto proprio bereguardo di
viaggio mi piace continuando a giocare
con il milan frattempo non disponesse mr
fantastici come lo andrò a modificare io
non ne ho la più pallida idea
eccoci qua allora andiamo a vedere nel
mio armadio delle decorazioni stanco
cosa potremmo modificarlo
allora in qua abbiamo un altro di
glitter sini pensa che prendo questi
arancioni perché ci stanno bene con
quello slime arancione quindi prendo
questi poi vediamo un poco abbiamo tar
[Applauso]
mimì coloranti ma il colore mi piace
così quindi direi che il colore lo
lascio veniamo qua abbiamo altri l'inter
sono tantissimi ma io più che altro
voglio renderlo un pochino più cremoso
l'affondo faccio il sederino di berlino
che sta dormendo berlino dorme sentisse
sposti il sederino posso vedere cosa c'è
qua dentro che nei pezzi però dai
vergani svolta questa coletto e sa che
c'è qui allora qua abbiamo tantissimi
ciampi allora prendo un po di lozione
aprendo anche questo shampoo così lo
faccio anche più morbido e profumato
stesso che il piace non lo so questo
sarebbe spettacolare ma presto questo
voi dite questo non mi piacciono questi
che saranno molto bene ok ora che ho
scelto gli ingredienti andiamo a
metterli per modificarlo speriamo che
esca bene anche se già lo adoro così ad
ammettere la lozione mischiamo diventerà
bello profumato
allora quando modificati 1 slime
inizialmente diventa un pubblicato
perchè potrebbe tornare tutto
appiccicoso potrebbe sfaldarsi tutto
muove dovete continuare a mescolare ea
volte
potete anche aggiungere un po di
soluzione per lenti un po di bicarbonato
per renderlo ancora più compatto in
questo caso non ce n'è bisogno questa è
diventato ancora più morbido che neanche
profumatissimo ora metto poco poco di
shock e che non crede profumatissimo
eccoli qua i miei bellissimi
azzeccatissimo color system europe la
andiamo mischiarli ma guardate diventato
ancora più bella
no quindi ci è voluto pochissimo per
modificare il mio live
vediamolo meglio le news live modificato
lo chiamo arancino a gironi un arancino
di riso
vediamo ora per evitare che di poi
potete scegliere il pensatore allora io
ho deciso di tenerli separati per adesso
è praticamente voglio fare per prima
cosa voglio mettere i glitter su questo
qui bianco perché ho in mente con uno
stadio fantastico e quindi qua abbiamo
la parte delle linee già ha preso il mio
tetto
allora lo lasciamo qui a riposare questo
qui greater mentre a quest'altro
aggiungiamo in color al peep letterato
più ha scelto che bella diventerà ancora
più ed ecco qua lo andiamo a mischiare
le mischiamo bene bene adesso ti sporche
rai un po le mani sicuramente in mano
fatti cordate chiuso con il club
che carino caro chiavi don backy che fa
gola che i cupcakes volevo dire la
musica alla fragola sì che cambi mori
indica clicca la fragola contro arancino
votate ora nel sondaggio chi vinse
guardo è pronto si può mischiare tutti
insieme così ora mi ritrovo provato e
bellissimo guarda tornerò fruit e sarà
difficile scegliere un vincitore per
questo primo turno si è mai semplice
modificati solo cari
vediamo che altro slam peschiamo adesso
per il secondo obiettivo branciamore di
tre gruppi a wow perché è bravo il
pescato un oro glitterato in su pesca
toe una sorta di cross valutari ok cosa
potremmo prendere per lo slime cross
silienzio prendiamo colorante forse è
meglio di no perché altrimenti diventa
troppo scuro il colore perché già è
abbastanza
sì è vero c'è una cosa che potrebbe
renderlo molto cari pigmento allora mi
trovo bene ho questo rosino brillando in
alto oppure un violetto ma puro che il
dialetto magari cambia il colore marrone
quindi prendo questo rosso brillantinato
ecocity capito o non è brava e poi
prendendo delle palline così la
trasforma in un bellissimo granchi e poi
prendo lo shampoo per renderlo ancora
più mondo
quindi queste sono le mie tre sentiamo
cosa si ammalano
ora io volevo aggiungere un colorate
utilizzerò questo colorante arancione si
dimena tra queste mogli a pezzi come un
galaxy voglio aggiungere anche le
stelline come galaxy koldo voglio
aggiungere le stelline e poi aggiungo
anche una crema per renderlo più
morbidoso ospitante quindi questi sono i
miei tre ingredienti dei prodotti
ora andiamo innanzitutto vedere con
questo slime sofficissimo e cremosi cosa
se che il colore stupendo sembra tipo
fragole e panna
wow qui morbidissimo
iniziamo modificarlo che vediamo un po
come s lo scià un po mi metto poco fuoco
così diventa ancora più morbido
mischiamo ei ha spruzzato un po di
shampoo per fortuna non la camera ma
solo nel cavalletto allora come vi
dicevo prima all'inizio c'è un po un
caos quando aggiungete degli ingredienti
perché dovete mescolare per un po finché
non vengono assorbiti completamente
dallo zar ok ora che lascia un pò si è
assorbito del tutto mettiamo un po di
pigmento vediamo come si trasformò
metallizzato
[Musica]
andiamo mischiarlo sono troppo curioso è
troppo divertente trasformare di slime
[Musica]
guardate che belle diventato un rosso
metallizzato cioè è stupendo troppo
bello l'effetto che gli ha dato il
pigmento e ora ultimo ingrediente le
palline diventerà anche un bel gran
siamo ma lo adoro è fantastico è stato
facilissimo modificarlo
wow mi piace tantissimo come lo
modificato e ora vediamo come lo
modificherà vitale si batterà in
quest'ora che col mio il galaxy gold
andiamo subito ad aprirlo io ho già in
mente come farlo tiriamo fuori la parte
bianca nella mettiamo qui da parte il
dischetto che andiamo a rimuovere e poi
tutta la parte trasparente con il tesoro
guardate stupendo allora mettiamo per
prima cosa il colorante arancione qui
che quasi finito tutto
non ho ben nota netta ti amo a mischiare
bene bene così diventa un pochino più
scuro ecco qua andiamo a prendere tutto
il colorante che mi è caduto qui in giro
arancione chiaro al giraud d'or algida
da quello di arida arancino e piccoli in
quest'altro giallo andiamo ad aggiungere
le stelline che ho scelto ti regala xvi
e affetto e li abbiamo già a mischiare
così possiamo includere anche tutti i
glitter possiamo mischiare bene e
vediamo un po che bello guardate che
effetto meraviglioso proprio infine devo
solo aggiungere la crema mani che ho
scelto crema mani qui su quello bianco e
andiamo a mischiare così diventa super
soffice morbido che bello super
morbidissimo ora la mia presentazione
sarà una pallina tonda tonda facciamo
tipo uovo con al centro
[Musica]
il galaxy dorato
ecco qua il mio ed ecco il mio quindi il
tuo galassi dorato il mio richiamo
utilizzino il giro da te chi vince
stretto dove sono tutti i due bellissimi
wow siamo stati problemi
hai visto che l'ho fatto originale
troviamo che dia un perfetto one
installare i miei più prezzi però nella
[Musica]
slide scorreggione nostri geni
modificati sono supercar e socio troppo
divertente modificarli ecco perché
questi crimi soft sono supersoffici ed
elastici quindi viene benissimo
modificarli sono bellissimi guardate
come in pochissimo tempo lo abbiamo
modificato solo di vedere gratis belli
mi raccomando votate nel sondaggio chi
vince per il prima per il secondo turno
e vi ricordo che potete trovarli in
edicola a solo 2 euro e 50 e ve li
consiglio assolutamente sono un bel mi
piace se volete vedere un altro video in
cui modifichiamo il di slime
e ora mi lascia un po a 4 caselline su
cui cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella che preferite e
buona visione
ciao